you
all right
whoa we have a nice crew here well it
did say 60 second ago 60 is a nice crew
awesome very cool I see some new names
in there too
I don't think I've played shy general
gun hi I'm gosu v2 queen master alright
we have a cool group of just about 60
for a 3o time control tournament shy
general gun first opponent yes
alright shy general Oh we've played
before
I didn't realize so this is our third
game let's go with a six sometimes
tricky to find the balance with this
time control I only capture there after
the bishop mode
position I'll hold off one move on
capturing d5 can be met with tonight a5
so let's see how that's different they
don't want to play with the isolated
Queen pond that's my impression of that
so now that this isn't a trap I'm still
going to hold my ground on this tension
because I don't want to help him come
out so easily so they've avoided the
isolated clean pond structure and we now
have what going on hmm
well it's from my bishop here I mean
where else is he going to go I think my
queen could camp out on a seven so I'm
kind of eyeing up the Queen positions I
think it's important that I secure the B
Foursquare I give up b5 but I don't want
to get my pieces kicked around rook c8
immediately
let's see it immediately they can't feel
so comfortable I want to think and take
with the bishop also I like that I have
queen bee 7 and some lines this is a
sensitive point on g7 also isn't this
kind of stuff right around the corner or
even Bishop here first this bishop short
on squares no d5 Bishop to d3 hmm I'm
just going to get that one in there
why did I do it like that okay let's
let's start with this I'm threatening a
bishop move with an attack against the
Queen
these bishops functioning on the
adjacent diagonals could be good I have
pressure against b3 let's play here
Knight here well I'm threatening on g2
so let's see what they do I have some
security for my a knight on f6 for a
while at least Queen is taking away the
fianchetto
I could still use a flight square I
didn't really anticipate that how about
I'll go in for a trade I think I want to
just take what's my queen she seems
pretty active now that there's a couple
minor pieces exchanged throwing a jab of
b5 I see could I just ignore that let's
kick him around he goes here there's not
going to be a capture here I want to
give up my Bishop so 9:00 to d3 Bishop
to d6 I still need a flight Square that
one he's pretty sideline though all
right how about
I don't like doing this but I just I
simply don't want to devote a piece to
babysitting the beep on so on Ponte so
I'll take here let's get a flight Square
and stop on Knight to g5 as well and
maybe you know what
I think I need to do this and try to get
to the seventh rank I put pressure on
these guys yeah I thought that that
might happen didn't realize I had this
move I have this square covered clean
exchange let's just double they're nice
out of play my queen is defended 'if
I've is defended their knight is out of
play I want to get here I have my flight
square 41 seconds okay
let's just jump in I'll take with the
pond okay let's do this
giving up f4 but I want to break up
these two guys also Bishop to f6 let's
jump back in here and surrounding a fork
I'll take with the rook now because I'm
hitting those two I've really active
pieces right now
I just got to move fast
get my riff playing this is the guy
won't give me the b-pawn I'll still take
what the rook is it's a fork I get
material evening out on the clock let's
just jump in maybe I take what the pawn
no because I could play Victor III let's
get the knight out of there
let's stay active I have a check might
get some pigs I'm looking for some pigs
now two pigs on the seventh second uhm
let's go here oh just take upon you
dummy okay now it's winning and now I'm
mopping up everything I could care less
about the double pawns I want this guy
let's watch out for any fanciness all
right now we could just push through
plenty of time careful yeah they
resigned
what's my quick thought on that game the
move Knight to e2 I think my impression
is that light did not want to play a
position type where they had an isolated
fund so they kind of acquired in a
position type that I don't know it
seemed like an awkward position like
they had to go out of their way let's
say they demoted their ninth
for example they demoted their knight by
going to what was it e to just to
reinforce D for it's not losing but I
think it was just an equal position so
okay what's going on here that Bishop
outside my pawn chain there is a
variation where you could fight for c5
I'll give that a whirl
okay not now there's some tactics like
this putting pressure on c5 and such
we're not there and I'm going to hold
off on castling because I might have
some attack here let's start with
Queenie to stay flexible I may even play
King f1 and just say I'm castled let's
actually try that when I try to make
something happen over on the Kings side
let's start here and they're not playing
a bishop move there let's let's do this
I'm threatening Knight here so they have
to deal with that threat first off and
they are let's go here they might try to
expand or something and challenge my
Bishop 97 them just dropping back oh
that's what they're going for okay now
we're just going to reposition I could
look to expand like this and I'm going
to I think I like that idea it stops
this as well and I'm going to try my
luck maybe what's taking with the pond
I think he could race down here and the
rookie get active so go with this and
now this position actually you know what
I can't move my night
so let's tuck my king in here you know
this here there's something hitting it
g3 so I have enough support for my
knight actually he can't be captured I
would recapture the pawn and land a fork
so I could go here um let's just do that
I could jump back in here I can rely
upon my queen as a defender of the night
so I'm going to sneak that move in if
later challenge I'll return the thing is
when the Queen comes here and then this
he still cannot be captured because of
the same threat there's a check but I'd
be I'm still on the night in that final
position 1:22 for team black all right
let's take
III try to make use of this wasn't that
losing so I could take here I'm winning
upon I kind of also just considered
taking
with a pond so I'm up upon though and
one more to say yes we're just going to
double I'm going to take with the pawn
now I don't want to give this night a
fast-track into my position so where he
needs to reposition so how about now my
king my king needs to get over here okay
now I get to push the night and then win
d5 I'm on the night he's under control
now I just go after everything else he's
going nowhere
fact
while for this night to even be rescued
get out of any pins
I guess there's rook here but this pawn
and this pawn controls two-thirds of the
ninth squares so he's really valuable
and I guess we just go here on this I
have a check some other King moving I'm
pushing through I could have also
captured the night I could have dumped
that as well yeah I wouldn't a bit a bad
move
just watch out for stalemates bring it
home and we're going to be there alright
they resigned back to tournament lands
and okay
d5 whoo all right let's try c6 slob
Springs
maybe we shoot for that connect Knights
Queen a5 Bishop be 494 start with this
not a quick Bishop development this is
what I'm looking for now White has to
take some care of these ideas to capture
on c4 and then Queen takes Bishop well I
could do this for starters before I
could take because in the end the night
will be struck out twice defended 0 and
he's in a pin okay then
what's the story here I could take here
I think I'm going to do that and then
I'm going to take here so I have the
bishops and they just dropped in their
night this is one of the sneaky tactics
that you have to be aware of with this
Cambridge Springs defense
I think that's the name of it at least
maybe there's some
that's not the exact move order anyhow
we got 841 minutes to go still V Pam 264
is up there 560 point zero Wow max
Walker chest let's try an e4 game be 45
let's try scotch what's black and throw
me that all right on it take cleanup six
here clean f6 I think the computer
considers Queen f3 is best alright let's
start with Bishop d3 this isn't so much
of an issue for black damage queenside
castle really you're not really
threatening to take here
let's just develop these are pretty
standard moves I think I want to get in
this I'm eyeing up a Queen f3 move but
actually before that let's do this see
how they feel about being in a pin Queen
here I have Queen d2
they moved I didn't see I want to keep
this pin I want them to squirm a little
bit
work harder to get out of the pin weaken
yourself to break the pin or move the
Queen here and then he gets in a way
here maybe at some point there's this
kind of stuff so King h1 is coming to
mind actually there is a threat of g5
here Queen takes bishop my F pawn is
pinned I should probably unpin my F pawn
let's just do it and now I can get these
these guys rolling 2 founds I have good
pieces here ooh
offering a queen exchange but at a cost
now I could take here or take here hmm
is it were
to give up the money bishop hare in
order to damage the kingside i'll give
that a shot
I guess we'll take with the a Brook or
maybe I even take with the knight now
say with this guy okay and let me see if
I could track down that dark square
bishop if I could get a knight for dark
square bishop exchange okay well they're
saying you know take me but help my
structure out maybe I still will down
[Music]
let's start with this I'd have to play
the
caPSURE i think i'm going to at some
point let's get this move in I would
like to see this rook move off of the a
file and then I'll make the capture
let's see how how long you can hold off
on that fish up here I could question it
further okay I'm just going to take note
and also here's the other thing
eliminating that who I expected to take
like this hmm yeah I think it would be
better to open up the a file I expected
a capture towards the center okay now
what's going on let's continue to
improve the king that move
let's stop they have a majority on the
Queen side 47 seconds
let's prepare to double here I'm
expecting c4 yeah maybe I should have
inserted this first so c4 doesn't hit
with an attack probably a 4 huh could
even think about this it may be a bit
counterintuitive hmm I'm going to keep
that guy around okay let's come over
here prep this kind of in advance 34
seconds they can't it's not easy to get
this majority rolling probably g4 yeah
they just dropped upon that is super
helpful now I have no concern about
their majority there it's non-existence
now
so I'm going to slowly improve I had
this advanced with Chuck I still do and
maybe I could even take yeah I could
take here I have this covered enough and
ooh ooh ooh I like that
that's a mate
Geller did have that one loose owner I
think I did
nice
all right a sudden end and I drop the
rape on so and then it was tough road
ahead all right we got the shy general
again playing is black this time around
where we throw let's try a Sicilian oh
look at this look at this queen h5 going
for scholars made stuff is that what's
happening
I guess I
all right let's see if the story is here
Wow get out there
I can also capture this poni
win upon next time why not
alright let's let's put a pond in the
center it's running a fork now to take
with the Queen epon is pinned how secure
this Queen feels on III C 5 versus D
pawn what do we do here
develop Wow am I
try to kill me let's go all the way back
this is one of their best pieces so I
should look to neutralize that guy right
now hmm here clean there I can live with
that I'll play g6 there's no winning of
c5 because I'm on the rook at the end I
got to do that
all right well this is the backward pawn
so what are they up to
let's start with this Knight here
maybe Bishop here first let's jump right
in yeah silly mmm that was so silly
there is a smoother way forward pretty
sure
I gotta do things that are a little bit
awkward rip b8 yeah attacking this guy
I'm just going to move them this also
stops any Knight g4 stuff I want to
challenge this Knight
hopefully I'm not getting killed with f5
got that covered I just want to get the
bishop playing okay he's playing I also
couldn't capture that pawn maybe now
there's this okay let's get this rip
doing something I think if I want to
just take with the rook just so my
bishop isn't so accessible why are the
tricks
let's take here let's get rid of the
Queen this is still a long-term issue
this pawn is backward
oh I didn't see that all right I'm going
to try something sneaky I think let's
see yeah they're just covering that
check this looks really awkward but I
don't want to drop a pawn my queen has
this responsibility not fun I was
looking for stuff like this still maybe
try for that at some point um cleans off
50 seconds not a lot of time let's try
this now I thought it would have
as I dropped the night though okay well
now they have a path c-pawn not sure
what this is I got it I got to defend
here and I'm in a fork right now okay
let's get within checking distance and
go for a queen trade hmm they're going
to get it
the Queen trade if they want it just
dropping a clear pond
now clean trade now 21 seconds oh man
yeah
have been so much easier 13 seconds
I had a forehead work there
I had another Fork no time three seconds
I have a push with check gotta be a
mouse artist I'll take a draw
holy cow with 0.6 there's no way that it
should have happened like that oh my god
well I mean I should have lost in the
end there but my point was in that
middle game position there's no I should
allow that night to sit on e5 and just
stay there and he was having so much fun
on e5 what more to say
oh just eliminate that night somehow and
then finally I could focus on the the
weakness on d2 they're backward pawn ah
that bugs me if you didn't know and okay
and they strike their Queen got really
active too
of control all right we got light to New
York on board in early advance there huh
all right let's castle and let's
challenge the center a little bit
looking to take and then expand
okay that really weakens stuff over here
huh so we're going to do this clean here
they castling let's try this I'm not
getting any concern of that now yeah
they're ready to sneak in there this is
probably a not too good of an idea huh
too many weaknesses especially this one
here
c3 yeah I don't even know if I should
capture that night
yeah he is a passed on c3 unnecessary
weaknesses let's also look at Queen h5
why don't I play that sooner
who knows another night
maybe I jump into c5c 5f4 let's platform
I would prefer to go here on the after
the bishop moves Wow
that does not seem right I think end up
being some big trouble now is clean h5
Bishop takes pawn next the King now has
to run for his life
pretty sure there's no bishop luck Oh
that my rooks there I guess must have
been the case well they didn't play that
final position right but I didn't play
the previous position right I don't
think this idea with a train before is
something I should revisit that's where
my opponent has space I shouldn't be
playing on that side of the board I
should just get on with these knight h4f
for ideas much sooner
25 minutes remaining this VP in the 64
is 34 points so the guy that has nearly
like 600 point increase all right let's
jump right in there
winning upon some trick I don't see some
trick here just giving me upon why why
is this play giving me a bone
what's not this Queen h4 stuff man what
did I do to deserve this
Queen h4 now it's just played to get a
reaction out of me I imagine well the
last person who did that against him got
a draw but they should have won so let's
play Queen h4 I guess I have to
for some fancy stuff right like takes
here here hitting stuff I'm throwing
punches right back
I thought about doing
first but I don't even want to give this
pawn up I'm just going to go here and
say you're nice in your bishops way
getting out of the way with an attack
Layla's look at this so this is probably
one of the most sensitive points look at
this
it's like beginner stuff man why is
beginner stuff being thrown at me he's
like one move threats a fork on c7 get
out of my house man get out of my house
I guess I guess this is a form of
trash-talking right somebody was saying
earlier when I said the I only trash
talk friendly trash talk against the
computers and they're like yeah right
yeah whenever you say get out of my
house you're trash-talking is that
what's happening right now
Queen trade come on man I'm off upon
Queen trade it's equivalent to resigning
isn't it should you be concerned about
this all right let's see do I even want
a Castle kingside
and give light any hope of cave mannish
stuff which is what's been thrown at me
so far a lot of caveman stuff
a lot of caveman stuff now isn't the
Queen close to trapped g5 try it right
here here pins sneaky
we'll take him
I got to be concerned about this guy
here he's a beast
she's a dancing queen let me tell you
but this bishop could challenge these I
mean both of these squares the bishops
can strike at no offsetting Knights I'm
leaning more towards going Queen side I
can force a queen trade this is a
maintenance threat queen bee for trap
the Queen May one cleans off and then
its mate
I don't care about this guy I want that
Queens off come get the Queen's off
oh look at the fanciness unbelievably
fancy clean trade pins oh no they have a
tactic now they have it that they had a
tactic all right we're just going to
babysit the night now yes you're down on
time too careful careful
you dummy you got nice there now ah man
not playing this right
please don't hurt me here
making here now come here to find this
guy there's still night check here you
die just like to f5 they didn't go with
Knight to f5 they've reinforced my
Center let's get out of that diagonal
I want this file to open up let's just
take stop Knight g3 throw a punch where
is he going give a check here one day
drop this pawn right who cares about him
you can see and even see he could take
that pawn doesn't have any time though
no time could have captured him back
ah man what's going on
holy cow yeah why didn't they win
material there I'm not sure I'm playing
this this final position brilliantly
this is beautiful technique everyone
should try this kind of technique
everyone this is awful I never want to
look at this position again never Malik
oh my god awful awful awful awful I lost
focus they rattled me that's that's what
I'm uh
I don't know to think they're dancin
clean master suite Queen h4 queen h5
Queen h4 Queen f4 she was having so much
fun raking the whole board
she made me dizzy
okay let's uh what's with knight c6
shouldn't this pawn be upset with black
right now
he's yelling at black right now how dare
you
how long to fight now I can't even move
okay I just think in general the D pawn
games this guy should be free to free to
fight
let's be a developer maybe we can win a
game that's not on time he's a loose
piece let's continue to develop I'm
going to clamp down on this idea or am I
to watch out for that he can't move
right now
what's threatened Bishop takes pawn h6
is good could try for this now the
knight moves e4 stops this and threatens
that so let's see what dead bones
unknown is it going to come up with I
mean right around here there's even
sacrifices I think they may have to do
something like that
Moon Knight takes pawn takes Bishop
takes e5 f4
let's give it a whirl yeah on e5 I'm
just playing
f4 straight away I want to push through
with e5 and also it allows for a rook
lifts
he's pretty sidelined so e5 f4 pawn
takes e5 there isn't a Queen move that
could do me any harm I don't think tough
pin to get out of huh
f4 let's do it there's no move here with
check why didn't I see that that was a
possibility
this should still be enormous though
because I'm getting a third pawn I
didn't see that move if I go here
there's a check probably just take it's
just I got some time here let's let's
see if I could to maybe calculate to
move Steve on takes pawn Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes pawn takes on the
Queen I like my dark square Bishop we
cover this with one of the puzzles right
big tsunami of pawns there and how about
we just move forward
on this I could push now that he's
defended Knight takes here and I have to
deal with ten more points entering just
want to drift all my pieces over here I
think he's kind of dead let's start with
this dual purpose here stop knight III
and yeah this is pretty devastating he's
trying to run let's just get one more
piece working
have captured that rook but
my bishop on f6 is worth of rook where's
the mate where is that mate how about we
start with this
it seems pretty dangerous got all my
pieces playing except for my bishop
really I don't even feel like I have to
take that night and let's start with
this check that way I don't allow it up
takes to be met with queen g4 and now
probably just take with upon our ex me
the rook now with a pawn and then uh to
mate and to Queen has to go here okay
but there's multiple wins rook h3 to H a
and you have to give up the Queen think
it's going to be able to sneak away
we're going to find out thirty seconds
only and they just resigned yeah I don't
think that one's going to be a way to
run away you'll count
the pan 264 seems kind of new
okay 13 minutes left I got 22 let's see
if I can maybe sneak into second first
time play why man my opponent just
resigned I thought first
that I was playing his white and I
forgot to move done that before
alright so now second is definitely
within range there's 104 in here
good to see okay I got fire let's try
another a for game you might Kings
Indian attack
okay maybe not now that white has black
has committed so early to that capture I
could just this is what I'm leaning
towards just bring the bishop out here
[Music]
where do I want to go with the bishop I
guess we'll go here and just castle I
was a bit hesitant because there's some
night move and my bishop is struck at
what do I do and this is a bit of an
annoying move Knight f4
let's do what to do okay how about how
about c3 Queen c2 they're playing like
instant moves like instinct moves let's
go here if you like they're preparing a5
somehow somehow I don't know how just
ahaha forget you're caught these guys
suffer a draw in a position that is just
so rich ja come on man it's a job
position plate I see this one is like
opposite color bishops where neither of
us even as a single pawn it's just kings
and office of color bishops it's nothing
to play for here ja let's just get a ja
ja like 11 moves in 11
why man I was ready to go here yeah I'll
form a one why not let's go a jab let's
show a little jab okay I think I have to
take now because there's this kind of
stuff huh ja you got to draw here oh I
don't know I guess we're going to go
here I need to get rid of their
LightSquared Bishop I think I don't know
mine is kind of stupid I've wasted a ton
of time also and I know yeah the game's
aborted why was it aborted man ah
one of those clowns shame on you man
engine abuser
if they were using an engine during
knocking but apparently previous games
they were disrespecting our game shame
on those who use engines don't do it man
don't go to that level don't do it let's
throw the French
all right here we go yeah let's go with
this
don't use engines man don't do it don't
go to that level it's not cool not cool
already I've had that happen
that's like a no it's like a certain
attribute in those he who use engines
like I have that before somebody just
offering a draw and then just a little
bit later like I don't know I like oh
let's mix it up let's not win every game
because that'll be too got too obvious
so we got to throw some drawers in there
and they won't be on to me that tactic
really worked that works really good
sucked off man come on just play chess
on your own what's that what why this
how hard what's the matter
okay now go for this I love this ending
I'm falling in love with this ending why
why am i falling in love with this
ending
because I have the better bishop that's
all nothing sophisticated we're going to
go here and try to secure my night one
day he's he's going to be so happy
I think move order man move order let's
make sure I can make use of this square
and this he might jump in takes and then
I'm kind of boxed out so let's hop in
right now so a four will stop B 3 B 3
will be very difficult to get in because
I have captures on a three so it's
official my night will be superglued
into seafloor no he's going nowhere and
I'll let the knight on c5 live for a
moment I want to make sure my B pond has
I want to make sure his presence is felt
and now I'm picking up a pawn how to
take how do you take here ear hand
doesn't really matter so much how about
this we're going to go here and just
revisit this square I'm trying to play I
know I'm up upon but I'm also just
trying to play against this guy there's
no bishop here right now so plus I avoid
in exchange with a knight that's a he's
a second-rank night how good is the
second-ranked night you know I have a
fourth ranked night versus a second
ranked night not all Knights are
positioned equally
3614 light now I'll return this is a
good block hater I'll be taking towards
the center and then that will open up my
rooks eyes to target the b2 phone as far
as castling is concerned I don't think I
need to counsel I want to keep my King
central he's going nowhere
he's a passed pawn but um I'm not afraid
of this guy so put a rook here right
there King here I just have to watch out
for these little fancy things maybe I
can open up the h-bomb if he goes here I
could fix another pawn on a dark square
just like that and now I even have
another square to operate from they just
drop the bishop
they resign back to term all right we
got 30 that puts me in second this guy's
on the stair VP into 64 four minutes
left 108 in this one let's see if we
could sneak in one more game well I'm
going to get paired up with one more
game but I be difficult to make it count
for the tournament should try my best to
make a count because I like high is
paused the one that's just behind me so
let's try d4 game d4 and how about
Bishop to g5 big variety there alright
we're going to go in for this and bounce
put a second pawn in the center and okay
let's just wrap a development I'll work
with just these two guys and all my
pieces out point towards the center
opposite their King F upon his pins so
not too much excitement here let's
preserve my knight and also I want to be
able to tuck my bishop back
I don't want them to be able to make my
Center flinch so I could keep this here
then I control a lot scoot the cleanup
so their x-factor bishop is not posing
me any problems just backup computer
would do something like this I think
seen that happen more on the queenside
let's get a flight square in and let's
just centralize once more clean d3 at
night here might be an idea God takes
and I'm threatening to chop the night so
like this maybe they're trying for
tonight c4 yeah but still okay here's an
interesting idea to take with the pawn
hmm now I should take with the bishop I
was thinking take with the pawn to sneak
in here that would be pretty deadly I
may try that though just for I don't
know now it's probably not it's playing
hope chess if I do that because a simple
defense is to simply play King to g1
this Knight has to be captured otherwise
I have this I could win upon no I I feel
like I should be going for some more
what more is there how about a night
reposition let's try this night into uif
five trends to win the exchange maybe
even clean the g3 okay so yeah I'll take
with the bishop I keep this diagonal
open yep
so maybe these three pieces can somehow
weave a mate against the king one minute
left in the tournament okay and I guess
we'll still look to maintain my pom duo
in the center
this uh pushed my queen to ask where she
wanted to go to if this if this rook was
here this would be a threat so I'm take
stakes clean here the bishop couldn't
move and how do you stop Queen here for
me so if look here this is like a well
it's going to say help me but the knight
doesn't have to be captured these sorts
of ideas are maybe close to happening
only five seconds for the tournament
what's the story here I'm going to make
a move okay maybe they're listening in
let's start with this threatening made
on g7 if pushed and I get this guy you
know the everything is collapsing
come on f7 don't know that I even want
to take that I want to go into f5 would
you perfect home now and now sneak the
Queen in here and I don't see how you
stop mate for long if to give up your
queen you know also 12 seconds okay so
they're going to block but I have may
now at f7 okay that's going to do it
Congrats to VP in 264 great results
slipped up at the very end about 51 is a
lot of points for a three Oh
5130 29 29 28 there's a real battle
going on for second and third just a
couple points separating okay
to me and all let's see all the pages
page two three four five six seven
almost there
and that's going to do it okay to the
107 of you to all who played honestly
good games all already